the family of sir david amos pours in to
read tributes and to remember
mourning the loss of a husband and
father
in westminster mps mourning the loss of
a colleague and friend
gathered together in quiet thought and
prayer may the bright memory of his rich
life
ever outshine the tragic manner of his
death
let us keep silence
i now call the prime minister
we've lost a dear friend and colleague
and julia and her children
have lost a loving husband
and devoted father
nothing i
or anyone else can say will lessen the
pain
the grief the anger
they must feel at this darkest of times
a tenacious campaigner who achieves so
much in his career sir david's best
known decades-long campaign completed
only after his death
he never once witnessed any achievement
by any resident of south end
that could not somehow be cited in his
bid to secure city status
for that distinguished time
i am happy to announce
that her majesty has agreed
the south end
will be accorded the city status it so
clearly deserves
sir david an example to follow for any
mp from any party
even as a political opponent he was a
man and a politician we can all learn so
much from because david held his beliefs
passionately
but gently
and i believe that not only can we learn
from that
but we have a duty
to learn from that
civility matters
and it matters in politics
mp share in their fond memories of sir
david but reflecting too on a politics
that has become far too toxic
he was appalled by what he called the
vile misogynistic abuse
which female mps had to endure online
and he told me very recently that he
wanted something done about
all of us can do better
not to feed into that corrosive culture
all of us have been a victim of it and
every single one of us
have a responsibility to put an end to
it
but the death of an mp in such tragic
circumstances taking us back the sister
of murdered mp joe cox nearly overcome
with emotion
i blocked out much of what happened when
joe was murdered
but i remember very clearly the moment i
took the phone call saying she had been
attacked
i remember physically trembling
and the visceral pain that overtook me
and it breaks my heart to think that
another family has had to experience
that phone call
and the nightmare which follows
is a roller coaster of deep trauma that
no one should have to experience
today is about david and his family
along with his staff
colleagues and the community he served
so well
the service he gave
and the support we should show all of
them in the coming days weeks and months
it is up to us to make sure that we do
because i know more than most that they
will need it and the powerful difference
it will make to them
after joining together in the commons
mps joined together again in church
for a service to commemorate sir david's
life and to mourn his loss
public service in politics
is a sacrifice that should be honored
and respected
even when differences of opinion
run very deep indeed
david showed that
divisions put aside mp's united in grief
it has taken the death of sir david amis
to remind them that they have far more
in common than what drives them apart
beth rigby sky news westminster